المادة 1 فاز تاي يونغ آهن 22 50 من الراشدين في كلية الطب سينغ هان سو جيونغ بتكديس المجندين الجدد
كان يوجد
[موسيقى]
رئيس مجلس الدولة في جمهورية كوريا الديمقراطية الشعبية نائبه الأول وتشوي هيون جو الثاني
جزء من الديمقراطيين في المحافظات الذين هم أعضاء سابقون في جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية ونائب رئيس لجنة نونا غونغ
أنا عضو في لجنة الترقية ولم يتم تنفيذها وأنا Jeongmin
حزب الرفيق كيم جاي جونغ ليفياثان 2 ومؤسسة توجيه التساهل التابعة للحكومة في جوانجيانغ سي.
عمال لجنة Sunwoo Orange المنظمة التي أكدت مشاركة الطاقم معًا
أيضا ، هناك عمال مسؤولون عن المؤسسة.
إليكم سبب أخذ كيم جونغ إيل استراحة من ارتياح هذا العام
بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، يشارك 15 كتابًا آليًا أو نحو ذلك ، كما أن Hani هي لغة Suri لـ Chilsung.
يدخل الرفيق والعمل عائلة أمول دوزا
كان من المؤسف أن أعرض هذا الدرس الخاص بالعين الاصطناعية
1 في الغربال الأوتوماتيكي عالي الدقة ، منذ ثقافة النجاح مع جميع أنواع الأبناء ،
إنه لأمر سيء للغاية أن تكون جديدًا على الحياة كصبي يتمتع بالحياة ويتدرب في المدرسة
ما يجري بدون المرشد الأعلى ، الرفيق كيم جونغ أون
آه
آه آه آه
[موسيقى]
آه
أوو
[موسيقى]
كثيرا
أوو